I feel like we're not gonna be able to
do this until we have one now we can
start the CSS all right I'm really
excited about this Cheetos Renaissance
that we're going through with like
everything is cheeto covered right now
do this minute you know this you just
smell fried this is like a Oh smells
like chicken I was like again I don't
see the cheeto nah at all I feel like
this isn't gonna get all over my pants
when I'm wiping my hands it's not
turning my fingers orange coughs cheers
to a cheeto chicken fries tears I don't
know I I just I can't paint the cheese
you're in yeah no I'm not I'm a tastes
like chicken
they need more Cheetos Burger King yeah
when she does any more Cheetos any
orange fingers still really good it was
like my third they eat the whole thing
really it's not that cheesy
I don't know I'm not mad I'm hungry and
this is chicken and it's fried I could
definitely keep eating these what drink
would be pair these with might be nice
mm-hmm cherry cola I don't know the bag
of like flamin hot cheetos of this I
could definitely say you should do a
flamin hot cheetos chicken fries I don't
hate it I don't feel anything
yeah that's that's a lot of my life too
well for me it's fried food at the end
of the day it's pretty good I'm gonna
keep this crown though oh yeah should we
make the hole
now understatement bye